states are stepping up to address
america's alarming shortage of teachers
but they're not
fun finding any receptive audience
especially with the biden white house
arizona no longer requiring teachers to
have a bachelor's degree which might be
fine and florida is offering temporary
teaching credentials to veterans without
certifications education secretary
miguel cardona is not on board with
those particular ideas
i do not support lowering any standards
for qualifications with teachers i think
we need to be creative and how we get
the teachers in for example student
teaching is four months of
teaching without pay i think we should
use the american rescue plan dollars to
get student teachers and give them a
salary besides throwing money at the
issue cardona blames the staffing crisis
on teachers not being respected
let's think back the last couple of
years you know our educators have bent
over backwards we went from totally
in-person learning to remote learning
overnight
yet the pandemic really pushed many of
these educators out of the profession
because
in many cases um you know educators were
not uh being respected when schools had
to close this problem is so widespread
it's all across the country some of the
school districts jesse are hundreds of
teachers short and they're about to
start next week and
there's just no solutions it's like yet
again it's like the baby formula crisis
they knew it was coming they didn't do
anything about it and then they're
probably going to want to claim some
sort of benefit or like that there's
going to be an air lift of teachers
somewhere well maybe they're short
teachers because they fired the ones
that wouldn't take the vaccine so just
hire the ones back i don't even believe
that they're short teachers they've been
saying this for the last 10 years i mean
maybe they feel like they're short
teachers because there's 10 migrant
students in each class
or
didn't like a lot like millions of
students just disappear from the roles
or just like leave the public school
system so maybe that could balance
itself out i'm just not trusting this
this press release they put out because
it came out on the same day the white
house called for teacher pay raises
so why would they call for pay raises
when test scores are going down that
doesn't make any sense to me
and like you can't criticize a teacher
so that you can't criticize the teacher
that calls your son racist
you can't criticize the teacher that
says your son isn't really a boy
like the the teachers that spend their
whole lives evaluating other people
can't be evaluated no not data that's
not happening okay there is a teacher
shortage i'll get johnny the stats yeah
you do that okay
okay but joey what do you think there's
a teacher shortage just like there's a
pilot shortage just like there's other
industry shortages because a lot of
people said you know what i'm going to
go ahead and retire when cove had
happened and there was no plan in place
for something like that and how to
backfill it on top of that the reason
why desantis wants to bring in veterans
and first responders to teach is because
that's the only group of people that are
confident you can pull from that aren't
already indoctrinated from whatever
liberal institution they went to and
aren't more focused on wokeness than
education and on top of this you're
saying something that's absolutely true
this is not pointing a finger at kids
but i come from a town i have educators
in my family if you have 32 kids in your
classroom or 22 kids in your classroom
and 20 30 40 of them are not english
speakers where do they put their efforts
that's a problem that means you need
more esol programs if you're gonna if
those kids legitimately are here that
school needs to invest in it where they
gonna invest in it from this is a
problem and to say we can't criticize it
is to say that we shouldn't take our
kids to school to begin with we have a
say in how our kids get educated we pay
for it we have a say in it and only
unions would say otherwise
harold what do you think
so i think
a lot of points made here with regard to
teacher shortage i think we have one uh
no one goes into teaching for the fame
and the glory and the money uh behind
teaching i think that
you look around in other countries
around the world teachers are thought of
very differently than we think of our
teachers here now we can say that unions
and other things have clouded this but
we need to figure out how we elevate
this too i i sympathize with with
governor desantis on this i think that
uh and i understand where the
secretary's coming from but if you don't
have teachers and you have people who
have degrees in the areas that you want
them to teach in
then put them through the two to four
week class and let them understand how
what it's like to be in front of in
front of classrooms now there's no
question we have a more current problem
where we have a lot of classrooms more
and more american classrooms where you
have two and three languages being
spoken so you're almost you're asking
teachers not only to teach uh and to be
proficient in english but to be
proficient perhaps in other languages as
well and we have to understand that as a
that is the case now we we did a story
last week i think
jesse might have been gone we were
talking about schools and we were
talking about absenteeism in some school
districts and it was an interesting a
group of teachers in a school district
realized that on mondays they had
greater absenteeism in some of these
schools and they realized because the
parents couldn't wash the clothes of
their kids over the weekend so what'd
the school do
they bought they brought they bought
washing machines and dryers i think we
have to think about these things
individually if hiring teachers who are
uh who may not have gone through
everything you want them to go through
like governor desantis is doing and
you're putting quality people in the
classroom do it it may work in florida
it may not work in tennessee it may work
in colorado it may not work in new
jersey but we have to realize that we
have a challenge we have a shortage and
we have to be creative about trying to
feel the problems
on sunday night because some of these
people don't have the kind of resources
that you and i have just they can't go
to the laundromat on sunday
just i'm just saying that school decided
to say i'm not sure i believe that the
school helped fix this problem
a lot of this is maybe perhaps also
being driven by um a burgeoning school
choice movement and acceptance of that
yeah that could be for sure i would say
miguel cardona is interesting he's like
you're lowering standards i went to
college um one of my professors he has a
he had a phd from oxford and he told me
that he wanted to teach at the public
school and volunteer his time in in you
know his retirement and the school
wouldn't hire him because he didn't have
the license let me tell you this nothing
scares the public school the public
education cartel
more than governors disrupting this
pipeline right because you have to go
through the teachers colleges and the
liberals know this the marxists own
these teachers colleges they run them
everyone has to go through them and so
they don't want any disruption what
desantis is doing is scaring the hell
out of them my father was um
was in the military for 34 years he got
out
he became a public school teacher but he
had to go back to school he spent
several years getting his master's it
would have been amazing for him um with
all the experience he had 34 years in
the military um he's he's so smart he's
so patient he ended up being a coach
this is a really great thing that
governor desantis is doing and i think
either saying you can your bachelor's
degree is sufficient your phd is
certainly sufficient um and getting rid
of of allowing this monopoly of of the
teachers colleges which are run and
partnered with the teachers unions uh
this is this is this is a real
disruption in addition to what you just
said dana which is this new opening up
of attaching the money to the child
school choice um homeschooling all the
things that have been opened up since
the pandemic i think woke a lot of
people absolutely hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else